oui esther et son mari jean redit ne se
sont pas vus depuis près de cinq ans en
haïti ils ont échappé un kidnapping
racontent ils après quoi ils ont quitté
le pays en 2017
genre 10 à 20 visa pour voyager aux
états unis il s'y est rendu avant
d'entrer au canada on a pris le chemin
jacques
chirac ça c'est magique accord parce que
ils vont là bas et vous voyez que tout
s'étale devant vous allez pouvoir
dévorer sauf que son rêve ultime de
retrouver sa famille ne s'est pas encore
réalisé il a un garçon de 8 ans et une
fille qu'il n'a jamais rencontré
esther était enceinte quand ils se sont
séparés la petite coralie a aujourd'hui
quatre ans comment vous allez
la famille explique-t-elle s'est d'abord
réfugié au chili avant de traverser
l'amérique centrale pour atteindre plus
tard les états unis
fin septembre la mère et les deux
enfants ont campé sous un pont près de
del rio au texas avec des milliers
d'autres migrants d'origine haïtienne
ils ont finalement atteint le canada le
mois dernier au poste de la colle dans
un songe à la frontière pour me
rejoindre et que on lui a refusé
l'entrée on lui a dit qu'elle n'est pas
qualifié genre 10 et france andré du
comité d'action des personnes sans
statut crois qu'il y avait eu erreur
nous et appelons le gouvernement
canadien en espérant que sur une
décision ministérielle sur le souhaitent
de les prochains jours qu'elle va
pouvoir un cri parce que tous les
documents où est évoqué la frontière et
pour une raison ou une autre à la
dernière minute on lui a dit qu'elle ne
pouvait pas rentrer oksa l'aude
ce passage à la frontière serait une
solution de rechange fermé au début de
la pandémie il est ouvert depuis la
semaine dernière on s'attendait à une
hausse et elle s'est matérialisé le
programme d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile de montréal n'en recevait
pratiquement plus dans les derniers mois
il en arrive maintenant une cinquantaine
par jour je pense que ça va être
mais je pense que ça va être plus seule
une ascension progressive ici on peut
dire
avec le climat d'insécurité en haïti
d'autres pourraient entreprendre le même
périple ton enfant touché nos mémoires
le genre 10 et esther touche au but ici
sébastien desrosiers radio canada
montréal